what's going on guys today i have an
official update regarding the
exact release date for my academia
season five
about a month ago it was revealed that
season five would be starting in spring
and usually you know when a micro
academia season starts in spring
it'll begin in april as that's what's
happened most of the time however
it has been officially confirmed that my
academia season 5 will begin
on saturday the 27th of march in 2021
which is pretty much exactly three
months and one week
from the date of posting this video on
the 27th of march it will be released
and as with most anime you can expect it
to appear on crunchyroll on that same
day
the dub for my hero season 5 has not
been confirmed yet so we don't know
if we'll be releasing on the same day as
the sub you know when season four began
that was the case
um but you know with the actors still
working from home and you know with all
the different changes that have happened
in 2020
it's unclear if the dub will begin on
the same day but i will give an update
if we get one
i anticipate that a new trailer season 5
will be released tomorrow like the day
after i post this video
um so be sure to subscribe because i
will be doing a reaction video
and a breakdown video once i've had time
to look through it
frame by frame by frame it's just what i
do guys it's just what i do if by some
twist of fate the trailer does not come
tomorrow then i will just do a review
whenever it does come but
i do expect it to be released tomorrow
with that said thank you for watching
and be sure to smash that like button if
you appreciated this info
until the next one peace out